what is up everybody how's it goin we
are here GameSpot live and today we are
actually sponsored by PlayStation now
which is what we're gonna be playing god
of war on i'm persia fair lights in the
building thank you so much for joining
us of course and we are playing God of
War today this is sponsored by
PlayStation now and if you didn't know
PlayStation now lets you stream more
than 800 PlayStation games on your ps4
or your PC plus you can also download
any of the 300 plus ps4 games in the
service directly to your ps4 s you can
stream and also download it you can
learn more at PS now.com and we'll give
you more details for that a little bit
later but I think we need to jump into
this game because I have been having so
much fun with God of War and like now
that it's on PBS now I was like this is
perfect
cuz I've been grinding it out we've been
I finished one we'll run through so that
we got a fresh new game+
for you guys the grinding you speaker
bye
please make a manual do you in that one
yeah and you might then move the mic a
little closer to you get over you get
nice and cozy with me come here all
right am i audible now I can turn mine
down a little because I'm pretty loud
all right by default
oh snap you're just telling me about it
I learned my lesson I learned my lesson
with this game because normally I jump
straight to that highest difficulty on
everything but God of War does not kid
around and when you do that it destroys
you and since I've already suffered
through at once and spent hours dying
over and over again I'm not doing that
to myself again I'm gonna I'm gonna
knock him back by one that's fine
[Music]
now if I still die in this tutorial I've
no actually has good arm room we're good
right now that was my excuse down the
drain right there you got this I believe
in him
[Music]
you know the first time I saw this scene
I kind of expected him to Ram
[Music]
spicy acts your favorite move
it's just a tree man calm down it did
nothing to you it has to serve a greater
purpose man that chest plate is so cold
I'm just looking at the disappointed dad
look as he stares down to the tree like
this is the price you pay
oh man the little bandage coming off the
arm this and that's so much more
significance after you play for the game
once and you know what that means later
on
[Music]
I found some
it is indeed the gun the bullet boy I'm
assuming you've already seen it but the
video of the voice actor for fateful
reading off dad jokes I have it I need
you that sounds amazing he does the
Kratos voice and he perfectly delivers a
whole bunch I've always enjoyed the
seamlessness between cutscene and
gameplay just don't want me to tie it to
the boat
Lewis says does someone want to start
the boy counting number one I'm already
immune to it I'm like ear of death to
Italy shudders enough we counted
something else the first time I played
through this game
father what a change this water purse
feels different this waters like to feed
be pulling the giant like I get the
Kratos ignores physics a lot of the time
caretaker I said how'd you get the
blades already new game+ yes we're
starting off with New Game+ and Persia
has already like done all the work and
grinded to get pretty much the best
armor and best weapons and everything so
I basically get smooth sailing and kind
of borderline cheating and and actually
look like I'm good at the game now if
you die that's a different don't you
diss me if I die now I have no excuse
I wonder why can't we just use the tree
as a weapon yeah at this point I would
feel safer just throwing this at
somebody it would be like the trolls and
their stumps that they use I don't even
know what the stick
my god it's such a it's such an
immersive experience the atmosphere the
ambience the sounds I love this game so
much
yeah and starting back at the beginning
feels really good
now they've played through the through
it ones you get to appreciate a little
it's the first time around
Jamie don't you hate on that thumbnail
okay they didn't warn me that they were
gonna do that with my face I think it's
great okay I will not cry this time I
will not cry this time we're not going
to judge its emotional his mother
their joy
hold there do I see my father
well there did they call to me
[Music]
I'm trying to keep it together we're
good I'm like getting warm in the eyes
right now but you can keep this together
I think when Kratos like picks up her
body spoiler there that was really that
really got me so
something about that particular camera
shot dad's home he's angry seriously and
then just the glowing chest plate that's
great
she's ready
[Music]
and the music and it's like
[Music]
it's God of War it's sponsored by
Ghostbusters with the little ecto people
on the armor there
[Music]
exactly or if she said who let this bowl
of onions in here how deep are we in the
story this is right at the start but
since we've already beaten the game
we're starting over but we have all the
weapons and armor on
the New Game+
[Music]
kath you're gonna have to get over it
[Music]
while Bojack you should it's a hundred
percent worth the investment absolutely
if ever there was a game that was worth
the asking price God of War is
absolutely one of them
boy I'm sorry
[Music]
squeeze no I thought you weren't
supposed to do that put ice on brain put
ice or snow directly I'm sorry no I mean
granted their gods get away with it but
I thought that was the bad thing disease
don't you taunt she knew shall we now
know
I'm hungry right now
[Music]
you needed a moment that's why these
sentimental
[Music]
this looks angry
which I know is fitting for the
character but it's still kind of amusing
what are we hunting you are two deer
which way in the direction of deer what
are we having for dinner food
I also also think it's great on a new
game musk is the boy on the side because
of all when he brings up just like elfin
looking dragon that legendary bow had
this casually laying around so we can go
hunt some deer with it
where did you find tracks not you though
I'll keep looking
into the lost-and-found you go with this
goodie that more tracks it is yeah but
there to around could be a wild boar
[Music]
this way boy I can jump that fresh don't
do that yeah don't hate alright awesome
thumbnails you are hunting deer not
chasing it okay first of all that was
not a deer I hate to break it to you but
deer are not like 11 feet tall with
glow-in-the-dark antlers
now that the opening scene to God of War
and the tutorial they do dragged on for
a little bit so I'm trying to run
through it so we can get to like the
first couple of fights you had one job
now it's guard is up only fire
holy fire when I tell anyone the
all-encompassing rage do not be sorry be
better find it
[Music]
by a trace has been through a lot today
alright just buried mom and then had to
go hunting now you got your bow taken
away and you will never please destroy
this the question is how I miss doing
this I'm forgot how sad
that's the counter we need the charged
heavy attack counter
how many skulls can we crack
I do want to punch one of them to death
so you can watch the full execution
there it is the little execution there
we go I want to see Kratos in mortal
combat I feel like he would betray me
oh that's an unlockable I don't know why
I try to the face
excuse me okay um so a game over brings
up a plane who says good evening huh
it's a afternoon for us over here but
good evening to you he's a great game
but unfortunately not on the PC well we
are playing this on PlayStation now and
you can play the PlayStation now games
on your ps4 or your PC so let's throw
that out there I got excited good
okay I keep trying to guard the
unblockable attacks in Iran to you it's
not really working out too well for me
no there it is I'm not dying on the
tutorial she's outta here he left me
wait are we still not done
oh no you're good no are we good are we
good please it just took a wrong here
they've never come this close to our
woods before moving Oh Chris was in an
k9 oh snap yeah I didn't really start
laying much of him gay until the most
recent one you know who is a really
surprising guest character for me was
negan from the war oh my god exactly yes
Tekin well the final lab today
the final fantasy character showing up
was already odd enough to me but but
negan yeah that one was definitely a
surprised I remember seeing the
announcement ievo and losing my mind
dang I want to go back and play anything
and I know it's like a Kratos can I have
my bow back now can you hit it from here
[Music]
no we should get closer by the battery's
sick of getting yelled ray a bunch of
times never wanted to take me by now the
story in this game is so good I'm not
like reliving it all just thinking about
everything I am I am reliving how much I
enjoy splitting monsters in half it is
just some of the most satisfying impact
you're gonna do that no no unguardable
stuff bad bad monster
that's what sagir
honestly you know what I just remembered
if you need to spin them out a little
bit
oh no I refuse to die I will use my rage
selfishly on these tiny little enemies
no no no no no whoa that was close
get out of here no y-you transforming
hey get out of here
I remember how to parry have the timing
unlock down should I use my resurrection
crystal oh I was actually too slow
that's a very narrow window did I miss
it I missed it I dodged the swing and I
forgot that he has the little lava blast
coming out behind it you went into that
base already
prepare the cheese tactics to whittle
them down a little bit from a distance
oh wow Wow
I got flashbangs I didn't realize that
that took us kind of yen I did not
realize I was playing modern warfare
candies frozen I love that
shanked in the back if I don't move did
they all like transform
oh man Jana beat the whole game before
they found out that they could find the
apples to raise their health that must
have been a really rough run towards the
end I feel like I needed every drop of
health so fun fact when you see them
Bendel's like backwards like that or
depending forwards and glowing for a
second they're not just changing their
appearance they are effectively leveling
up and becoming a more powerful enemy so
they can do that oh hey look execution
Oh
oh they don't kid around yeah I think
Lee once they are all read the next hit
they all just automatically explode okay
it's not just like that this time around
this time around I'm on a plate I'm
gonna fight dirty because I don't like
losing
okay so we're gonna we're gonna bust out
all of the cheesy tech Ozzy I feel like
the real cheese within the blades of
chaos I just keep swinging over you're
not you're not wrong at all
I personally find the axe so satisfying
all you were trying to do is do it I
tried
they probably
oh so good the animation they're so good
Kratos goes down like a sack of potatoes
okay
these these these self-destruct yeah hit
throw the axe at him to make them pop
their little yeah okay that's the ways
of missing I think when you play it the
first time these guys aren't a high
enough level to use that so I don't
think I ever had to deal with that the
first time I played okay that little
that little self-destruct is really
messing me up no three this startup on
that was so bad it's a very little
warning
[Music]
americo's now we're busting out the
blade we're doing it yeah oh yeah
destruction please a sick man you gotta
give him that do the Scorpion on him too
with the with the blade I actually don't
remember the button even for that it's
the same as the throwing that with the
r1 come here get over here PC gameplay I
wish
what yes you can get on PS now and it
plays perfectly smooth on the
PlayStation thankfully and honestly for
games like this
realistically I personally prefer
PlayStation controller anyway but that's
just me I don't know I grew up playing
fighting games on console and the
PlayStation controller is my input of
choice no matter no matter what platform
I'm playing on so even if it even if it
were on PC I would still want the
controller for it yeah I think you need
to actually use a Playstation controller
when you play on PC just as a heads-up I
love the puzzles in this game actually I
think they're really really fun what
difficulty is this we are on challenge
it's the one right below give me got a
war I recognize full well that having
not having not really played it since it
came out I felt that trying to put it on
stick hardest setting would have just
not been good right but it's not on
normal either so it's still pretty hard
good he's so adorable
Atreyu he grows on you by the end of the
game the first time I played the game I
just kept trying to figure various ways
to like maybe accidentally elbow and
waffle I was like how do I get them how
do I get a kid that quit following me
the game would be perfect but you know
by the end of the game he's okay yeah a
little bit finish what you started the
only time I didn't want him around was
when he like found out he was a god and
then he started being a little jerk a
little bit yeah it's like you might be a
god but you're still 12 so you need to
calm down
yeah exactly I can't man I kind of
forgot about this scenes and makes the
later scene where he embodied with that
guy like even crazier today no look what
you've done
Kratos drama don't you feel terrible we
gotta eat boy baby boy bringing let's
bring the pot
ah those moments when he's like about to
be dad and he's like no I'm a god of war
how dare you kill steel that's not okay
in any game what you guys I remember
this fight the first time I tried it
taking me several events
see how we do this time oh my god that
hurt
one thing is destroying your sun
protection
Oh
one please so brave that's his most
predictable
[Applause]
you've added your troll you're
predictable
now I know he starts doing other stuff
we staggered and we could have got a few
more hits in there cuz I staggered
already oh he did the double tap oh he
got me good so when I use my little
Resurrection crystal so it takes three
years for him to kill us so we get we
get to make two errors that's all we're
allowed in this fight is two mistakes
Naga says what you can actually carry
the pillar yeah that was news to me as
of right now oh oh that's ok stomp
doesn't really do any damage
damage control huh okay I was 10 feet
away show you stomping on you come over
there
give me a stagger stagger right saige
he's like a tree is blindly attacked a
huge troll but couldn't finish one beer
because the deer was innocent very this
there's a thief
and we don't condone this oh now okay
now we're into the wild swinging stage I
believe he goes one two three four and
then he gets dizzy or is it once you
treat dizzy there it is oh my face into
it okay
he's gonna go for the double no he's not
okay it's hard to predict what he's
gonna do he's already down to have
health oh we're doing much better yeah
just one two three four oh my face
oh that's a spicy meatball totally got
this should I use the Spartan god of war
rage you can use a traces ability it's
pretty good it might stun him enough for
you to
[Music]
see sometimes he does a little poke into
the overhead thing and that's that but
then sometimes he does like two more
follow-up little swings so I've gotta be
real cautious because this point where
one mistake from dad okay let the boy
take a few hits
I think he's within range level yeah we
probably can he's gonna get dizzy
while the errors did surprise
yes at Reyes has a lot of plot armor
there we go we go
[Applause]
music music yes that's right boy that's
yes just like dear old dad just let them
rage out you are not ready
what are you serious it's like do you
not see this I proved myself already we
are going home I haven't been sick in a
long time I can do this
[Music]
you did just kind of wear yourself out
on a dead troll yeah and by the way you
guys today's stream is sponsored by
Playstation now a service that lets you
stream hundreds of PlayStation games
directly to your console it has classic
ps2 games ps3 games all the way up to
today's biggest ps4 hits like GTA 5
Uncharted 4 and God of War which are
available to play until January 2nd 2020
you can also download any ps4 or ps2
games straight onto your ps4 so you can
play them offline at any time it's as
simple as loading up the page within the
game PlayStation now app and hitting
download and that's what we're doing
today actually with God of War so hope
you guys have been enjoying it so far
and obviously so much left of
PlayStation now we're hooking it up
necessarily super familiar with the
answer but what would be the like actual
difference taking advantage of
PlayStation now versus just installing
it on your your Playstation hard drive
so the biggest difference will be how it
runs or plays and the fact that you
could play it offline so if you just
stream the game from the platform
you know it'll play perfectly fine it'll
be great but if you get disconnected
then you won't be able to access the
game so if you want to avoid that I
missed that last part because I was
written in half with my bare hands there
we go Oh interesting we have the crystal
now I think unless we don't have it yet
let's see does this carry over to new ok
it would be kind of weird if you could
go straight through the straight through
every door right from the get-go
one of them I killed in a single hit
might throw on the eggs yeah I think the
difficulties too hard
denied
[Music]
hit me while I was down what a cheap
shot PS now is its own app within
PlayStation and it does have its own
membership okay that was not the button
I'm in arrest but since I pressed it
we're gonna roll with it we're gonna lay
the smack down we're just going in
because I one year of PS now is $60
which is the price of one game that you
would usually get and there's like over
800 games on the platform that you can
play I think it's pretty worth it that
is really hard math to argue that's
actually a great question
is there is there games from previous
Playstations on there as well or is it
yes there is ps2 ps3 and ps4 games on
the platform Halloween just ended but we
streamed a bunch of like spooky game
he has now had a lot of really good
options and old school ones we played
Silent Hill 2
Linderman was super scary but it's
definitely
No you've got that little self-destruct
we're not gonna fall for those gimmicks
anymore fire boy yeah they even do
damage to each other when they're near
each other or Han said you should switch
in one of you guys he's not gonna die
anymore he's already remembering the
mechanics and the system it's like
riding a bike I say yes I just get
dunked dogs across the screen by a bass
Academy oh my god are you for real
I'm sitting here hitting you how dare
you not let me just hit yes be a polite
monster and take that out here someone
growling oh oh these are the guys that
laugh at the ax so I gotta just talk to
the hand ball bounce
definitely the smackdown
or a form of it this was one of my old
you not to speak the rock-bottom
aha that's what I'm missing right there
but why would a financial burn mother's
garden this is the part I remember this
is a lot of fun now be silent almost be
silent about what wasn't he bowled up
balls were when I fought him the final
time I didn't know that was the last
boss of the whole game
and I was giving Soze all right or the
last time I would fight him I didn't
think that was gonna be the last time I
thought he was gonna come back again
later on I was like what I felt like
they did a fairly decent job of making
it clear that the mistletoe arrow would
break his indestructible charm thingy so
I was like this very well be the end of
having to fight this guy over and over
again and honestly by the third time
you're kind of ready to like not keep
fighting the same guy anymore than three
versus the same enemies just let him die
yeah we've killed him three times let
him die and he's so strong
um that is a good question sniper asking
about multiplayer games and if you can
play them with your friends I would
assume so because they have Grand Theft
Auto 5 on the platform right now and you
know that's one that you can easily play
with other people
[Music]
time ran so cool in the dark sweet
glow-in-the-dark because we're a god you
lost control that thing was trying to
kill us but Kratos himself yeah he's
literally ripping people in half with
his bare hands I haven't been sick in a
long time I'm better not when you use
your Spartan rage he literally throws my
weapon away just so that he can punch
them war it's like the very definition
of who you want in troll he want me to
hate I want you to try out diesel try
again
why are you doing too slow try again
yeah week again week again your anger
you can get lost in it that way it is
difficult and you are trace are clearly
not ready
oh it's time
there's gotta be rough is a Kirby vacuum
cleaner salesman more importantly I know
what you are boy
use the floor now I do think it's
interesting the idea of having gods from
Greek mythology running into gods from
Norse mythology and then kind of having
to figure out where they will stand up
against each other in terms of like you
know how powerful they are okay all
right small fry look who's talking
long way from home aren't you
what do you want oh you already know the
answer to that whatever it is you seek I
do not have it you should move on and
here I thought you're supposed to be so
enlightened so much better than so much
smarter and yet you hide out here in the
woods like a coward do not walk this
fight
I'm pretty sure I do voice acting is
superb in this dang the backhand for
real you are going to have to kill me
for that to happen
I warned you I know says what the entire
audience is thinking finally you know
not listen what's really interesting
here though is why would you know a god
from Norse mythology what why is he so
confident that he's more powerful than a
God from Greek mythology they have
nothing to compare it to right he's
never fought of every Greek God might
okay yo the phrase I my father
how disappointing
I got a crack get up in the air where I
can W sir
[Music]
they send them flying nope
nice
yeah the Perry's are ongoing in this
this first iteration of this guy yeah he
basically just shows the same attack
over and over and over again so it's
pretty easy to carry it but he's gonna
change it okay how can I can I interrupt
what I was saying to defraud an out he
doesn't start to bury up his pattern a
little bit more so it's gonna get more
challenging here in the second phase
alright why are you that observant and
why do you have so many teeth
it's alright knock them all home using
it as a weapon there we go there's some
tree trunks
even this up a little bit okay
what can't I do that I know I need that
IRL you never fall to looking again
that's like drinking the cop I love that
the rage instantly went full meter is
like excuse you push that button
so powerful
we're one
my punches better
you know you unlock a bunch of different
abilities that you can use in your rage
form but none of them in my experience
wherever as good as to just punch them
repeatedly option that that seems to
defeat the best bang for your buck
although some of the others do look
cooler like this one looks like in terms
of just actual damage oh I couldn't
dodge that one that her
No
you are having way too much fun with
this why I question him cutting down the
string with the accident what yeah from
the look of this he could have just you
know just poked the tree with his
fingers now that little self-healing gag
that he did though he's not the only one
that can do that it was so cool watching
this the first time you played the game
because you don't know that Kratos is
capable of doing something like that and
then as he's walking away you're like oh
that's right I'm a god how does he not
do it yet maybe that's not something
that's a matter of thing that's exactly
that old body will get out before I am
this I want you to know one thing I
can't feel any of this
Oh
[Music]
holder's definitely one of those guys
that like the real way to deal with him
isn't fighting him you just gotta like
you gotta trap him in a box and throw it
exactly I don't want to deal with this
anymore yes I do because these fight
scenes are so he didn't have to be this
way
it really did though it would be you
think about it you didn't give me many
choices here it comes here it comes
alright I'm a god yeah let me just
[Music]
finish
finish this is not the right term for an
enemy that's going to recur yeah for the
super game exactly
you baited me with the timing on their
music when I thought he was gonna zag
and kick me in the gut oh my goodness
God Oh babes in the chat that he's
basically Conor me is Conor McGregor
except more polite
[Applause]
over here oh there we go that was some
good damage on that no it's um very
smooth juggles do you know you won't I
have another sequel to do a lot of
damage
it's okay though we're still in there
he's he's hurt - oh okay we're still
good all those clothes I thought that
was it actually
not like this come on give me one good
Perry that's all I need
there we go
that angle again here we go
just call me mate India's baby joke
about hey there we go go to sleep
leave me five stars on my Yelp page best
chiropractor in town all of your
customers sleep soundly forever
[Laughter]
was he oh man he's hurtin fine
after all this time what do I do that
line definitely got me in the heart
do the god trick and heal yourself you
gotta wonder how many times he can get
away with doing that I can't help but
imagine it like must drain some of his
internal stamina see he did it right
there but we cannot stay here yeah time
to go well considering he demolished
half of his house using it as a weapon
it's a good time to reload relocate
anyway
boy you know what amazes me though oh so
much boy actually stay put
stop all right he actually listen I was
waiting for him to show up during the
fighting would come gather your things
but I wasn't ready you are not they he
had the same no choice now
some somehow Kratos strikes me as the
kind of dad you don't want to play the I
tell you so game with yes sir
you got a month of Playstation out just
for this game and it was a hundred
percent worth of heated last night
[Music]
exactly
and in case you guys did not know
today's stream is sponsored by
Playstation now a service that lets you
stream hundreds of PlayStation games
directly onto your console it has
classic ps2 and ps3 games all the way up
to today's biggest ps4 hits like GTA 5
uncharted 4 or got a warrant which are
available to play until January 2nd 2020
and you can download any ps4 ps2 game
straight to your ps4 so you can play
them offline as well it's as simple as
loading up the game page within the
PlayStation now app and hitting download
that's what we're doing today with God
of War
so yeah let's continue on to the
mountain let's do it I'm trying to
remember what is the next major
confrontation that we're gonna run into
but it's uh it's been just long enough
that I can't remember exactly right next
which is perfect because then you can
kind of be sort of surprised when it
happens there's really so much in this
game to be honest because I beat it you
know a few days ago as well and I don't
even remember what's it did you kill him
well you know what amazes me about this
game though is that they added so many
areas that you might never even see like
optional area poison mist area and the
fire world like there's at least three
zones in the game that you could skip
entirely and they put so much detail and
depth into them and so much stuff you
can unlock and and equipment to grind
for so just you know just cuz you beat
the game doesn't mean you're done yet
there's still plenty of zit to do and
that that kind of like extra level of
content is something you don't see in
games these days you used to true and
super legendary stuff in these new areas
obviously it's really difficult but it's
cool definitely gave me like the itch to
keep playing
after the story was over which I feel
like it's kind of rare for me nowadays
with games but this one does it really
well
I used to be very much a completionist
but now usually when I beat a game
that's you know I'm done I'll move on to
the next the next story the next
adventure whatever
this isn't the big fire we just fought
the first troll and but later on there's
a poison troll and then there's a fire
troll all the trolls kratos is getting a
comma I definitely love the puzzles in
this game they could be a little bit of
everything I love in a game fun combat
with combos you know a little bit of
grinding for legendary lieu puzzles and
also tug at my heartstrings they
literally give me everything
speaking of combos you told me you're a
big fighting game fan and you play
Tekken right yes
[Music]
she's new she just came with this most
recent DLC you're talking for Tekken 7
yes yes I know she was in some of the
earlier one right for me I've only
really been playing Tekken in seven the
most recent one and a lot of my friends
who play they've played since the first
one and they just have all this legacy
knowledge the legacy knowledge in Tekken
is very strong to some of those
characters have had the same combos
since the 90s
you're fighting them you're just like
I've seen this trick now for going on 20
years I know this combo Oh smash Santa
Monica studio in the chat what is up
thank you okay
I got distracted talking about cams
paint head I feel like I missed
something important so I'm gonna go back
up here and try this again okay what did
I miss
that's what I know that's just a piece
of loot that doesn't get us out of here
all right here we go this hogs
okay we're supposed to climb up there
well let's go grab the loot I'm not
leaving without the loot gotta have my
shinies okay now let's move on how about
I got to put the drawbridge back down
again I let go of it like a dummy
there we go
Santa Monica studio said we never bought
this game for no like streaming
technology is amazing isn't it because
there are so many games you can stream
on PS now and you know when they were
made even the ones waved back on like PS
us ps3 you know they weren't made with
this in mind yet it's still running so
smooth yes I might be a little bit
biased but I have to say I'm also a fan
of the scene I think we're coming up on
this is the this was this was the
do-or-die fight when when you're playing
this game for the first time especially
if you're playing it on the hardest
difficulty I'll know it when I see it
it's like the first time you encounter
the big charger type in the big brutes I
spent three and a half until I realized
the key wasn't fighting them it was just
choosing them off the edge yes I loved
doing it walk the tree she wishes for
her pyre when is God of War wife gonna
come out that's a good question I wish I
knew the answer to that one fantastic
question no pressure
Santa Monica video I'd like to point out
this is a question from the YouTube chat
yes being addressed to someone in the
twitch chat yes that's all the cross
chat going on with us as the
intermediary so Santa Monica
Hamza wants to know when god of war five
is come oh yeah I don't think we're
getting a straight answer oh yeah
definitely not although that would be
awesome
however no pressure I will gladly wait
until it is ready because this games so
beautiful that you know you wouldn't
want to rush a process of making the
game to follow this one I have always
appreciated when's it gonna be released
when it's ready
exactly No
that was where's the deer in the
direction of deer moment Alan says here
is hoping for a God Aurora movie in 2020
you're looking at it right here this
story and this game was so good it is
very movie like to me oh that right as
you were in there please nurse hey why
is he able to do that when I'm in swing
but just for that you get the throwing X
cheese loading noise now the indicators
are so critical excuse me
Oh
oh we've got more Oh give me that give
me that give me that
thank you very much Alan said the rock
would be the perfect grater larog would
just be the perfect anything I could see
him in every single game movie ever why
not I mean did you see the way greatest
like jumps certain gaps the rock did
that on that skyscraper move in
no the projectile interference no let me
get my head off the projectile dude
needs to die oh you know what might help
if you switch your arrows to the light
arrows because it does like electricity
stun which is pretty good to get them to
stop interrupting in from the distance
that little multi arrow thing that he
does is actually quite helpful yeah it
has a long cooldown but it's really good
and it stays active for a long time too
oh there we go no those little the
self-destruct yeah can we get a live
like hot fix patch so the game just
remove that self-destruct hotfix
incoming they're just deleted from the
game it was Russia shot the Santa Monica
Studios agrees that the rock is the man
[Music]
get out of my face not you too quit
interrupting my conference I feel like
this game has been out long enough to
where you know we can save some spoilers
even though that was a massive spoiler
haters but you guys now it's time to
play if you like to see if you like the
story so far you know I just remembered
and this totally slipped my mind till
now but if you do the execution-style
kills I think you'll regain health oh
and I completely forgot that so I've
been running around on low health I'm
pretty sure if he just you know punch
some sense into this guy I have mostly
been using it just to be invincible and
like when you're in the animation you
can't get hit by anything else so
sometimes I use that just to avoid you
to get health back when you use your
rage every hit you land gives you a
little bit help
this is also another very effective form
of Jesus repeatedly abusing them he
tackles works very well
why hello sir
where's projectile dude you need to die
you projectile dude throw him sometimes
I forget how to do it but there is a
move you can do where if you don't have
the ax in your hand
and you're running towards an enemy you
can have the ax lie to you like midnight
but I don't remember the arts you while
it's in the air I think he saw how it
was like flailing away
well that was a very short-lived break
yeah the meter was oh there's the
projectile guy No
yeah there we go the ones up there
usually lower health so that you can
kind of pack up those thankfully can you
imagine if they have full health yeah I
have to throw my 12 times to sign the
wars but only would sleep to do so
that's right you aim and then press r2
while you have the ax al yeah Thank You
Optimus Prime I remember back when the
game first came out and I was playing it
every day and I had hours on the end of
practice you could get to the point
where you could you could use the blades
of chaos to do the scorpion style get
over here and then you could like while
you're doing that switch back to the axe
launch them into the air throw the axe
after him and then tackle it down a bit
like playing around with stuff like that
was a lot of fun and still is but it
definitely takes a considerable amount
of practice to pull off some of those
really cool-looking combos at least the
first time you pick up the game just the
standard hit them into the air and then
smack them as many times as you think
your energy works really well and that's
mostly what I've been doing today cuz
you can pull that off with very little
practice wow wow
when I'm reading my boys chest that is
rude to put the axe away for this guy
too
you're gonna catch it this is for
interrupting my chat experience you know
actually I wonder how the plates of cows
work on these ice dudes because the
first time I played the game I didn't
have the blades versus cars so I didn't
really get to see it and it's fire so
fire elemental weapon versus pice
enemies that should like in theory this
should work it really well exactly
I've always loved the two-ton chest for
the 3 pound bag strategy that's also
great great way to protect your loot we
are playing on the difficulty that's
right below the hardest one so it's not
normal but it's also not the hardest one
I forgot what it was thought it's like
give me a challenge or something like
that yeah this is the second hardest can
we all just collectively take a moment
take your hand up and apply the palm to
the side of your face wait if we wait
[Music]
I don't need kids IRL this party enough
for me dealing with I'm sure you and
whose antics slow down your haste will
cost us that is a lot of zombie listen
Big Mike thank you
yeah uh more drawler
but these aren't moving are they dead oh
I remember this part now Morgan
boy boy you about to touch it
yep this is the scene that took me
nearly three and a half hours the first
time I played the game on the hardest
setting this this scene well it's up to
you to do it in minutes
oh man we need to make some good that's
why the blades are good cuz you can hit
them from a distance
well I'm more so worried that if I use
the blade oh yeah they're kind of player
tapering they're fire-type but also I
don't want to bump an enemy that is
about to do his little self destruct see
the way the way they do that thing where
they get ready to self-destruct if
you're like kind of flailing the blades
in circles
you're gonna hit them and trigger the
self-destruct constantly that's kind of
what I'm worried about
but who knows you know what maybe it's
big like not super close to me that
thing might be like just outside of the
range we're good I want to wake them all
up so that I can do the big spinning
attack
hey guys all of you wake up please okay
now all of you gather round here we go
Binda win smash a chess lady that oh my
gosh everyone's stunned if only we
stayed that way forever eases I'm gonna
get a couple of them at least
oh yeah I'm certain I turned on the kids
to keep them stunned
you got the setup no no no no no stop
leveling up yeah yeah you're definitely
clearing him out l1 r2 is good also back
to the old strategy of just dump them
all off the edge cuz that's how I got
past this scene the first time
and this isn't even the hard part the
hard part's fun the big guy right are
you gonna stop this truck
there we go get those stuns in there
instant kills you know I never really
did explain that for people who haven't
ever played the game before when you see
that little glowing red icon that means
you've stunned them and you can get an
instant kill if you get in there and hit
them before they recover usually
definitely on these little minions will
fight some bigger bosses that you can
stun but you might need to do it a few
times but you get all the good damage
your l1 and B is also an ability o for
circle too many consoles all right you
got this I believe in you all right
these are the warm-up runs this area is
giving me painful flashback spending
hours here the first time fourth times a
charm
oh come on come down here we go come
back here now I notice sometimes they
get instantly stunned if I could figure
out what's doing that maybe it might be
a part of some of the items you're
wearing that have a chance of stunning
on certain hips up like that so a
combination of everything
this oh boy lots of red indicators red
indicators my
hey we're good for kids I don't even
even hurt
all right kiddo do it do your do your
crazy stunt move get off the clip
no no I didn't see the red indicator
behind me right fifth time's a charm
we're getting there we're gonna get
through this seat this is my dad this is
my goal for the day I came here just for
this now the power moved up like the
Special Attack power move things I can't
remember are they shared like if I use
the Power Move on one does it assume the
meter so I can't do it on the other you
can use them as long as they're cool
down
right but using the I guess what I could
use one like rapid succession like one
after another
yeah can I do it can I do it with the
accent switch to the blades and use that
one yeah yeah you can
[Music]
you
Oh
there we go it's time for the old spin
down it's time to bake so easy kills
you got this feeling it's two people
- people use this oh yeah yeah they're
all waking up now
[Music]
okay all right very good
oh you got someone up top sucking
fireballs
nice some random dodging him a little
bit of luck dodge those fireballs thank
you I'm lucky arrows I'd like to file a
complaint with your manager
tonight betrayus thank you thank you
boom now I'm pretty sure that was like
phase one of three now it just gets
worse control or is that it is that it
and now you thought the bus didn't after
you there's more I know this scenes like
that they make you think you're good and
then they just come in to destroy your
hopes and dreams I think you have to
read the wall yeah yeah yeah read it and
then it's all done now now the hard
parts here I come
yeah like 20% health we're in there
I've almost got mine x-ray John Locke
that might help
no one likes you go away this clip Wow
can't actually knock the big guy ah
hey guys to buff well I just miss time
to the parry on that one actually that
move was a little slower than I thought
yeah you can't all throw the heavy guys
off the edge unless you stun them and
you get the little instant kill
execution animation then you can grab
them in drag but thankfully we had a
checkpoint I don't have to clear the
first now if I remember right it's
actually more effective punch these guys
yes shock him off me it's all you did to
their boy
do it twice that works for me
nice
[Music]
nope no not today get out of here I'm
the God of War get out of my face right
on time actually now is that actually
the end or is there a Phase three
don't do this to me game oh this is it I
think success definitely way way way
better than my first try oh right and
this is actually the perfect place to go
ahead and wrap it up you guys today's
stream was sponsored by PlayStation now
with PlayStation now you can stream
hundreds of ps4 ps3 and PS to games
directly to your console or PC with the
new games being added every month in
addition you can download any ps4 game
in the service on to your console to
play at any time and they have hits like
fallout 4 NBA 2k teen MK X and rocket
League so you can learn more at PS
now.com and that is gonna be it for us
today we hope you enjoyed watching us
play some God of War I definitely did
hope you had an amazing time with us as
well it was satisfying revenge on that
whiskey after getting destroyed there so
many times before but in addition to all
of the PlayStation now stuff it's worth
it just for God yes seriously like
picking up the service is it's only for
this one game it's worth it and
everything else is a cherry on top
exactly and you know one year's 60 bucks
which is the price of one game nowadays
so it's definitely worth your while
especially if you like playstation games
from 2 to now hope you guys consider
picking it up and hey let's play some
games sometime alright guys that's it
for us and we will see you later
you